we were gone for quite a while
but no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its
Guardians hello become in peace
come on Drax seriously dude
we'll all fly away together one last time
into the forever
And we'll kill anyone who gets in our way
no, not kill anyone kill a few people kill no people
kill one guy one stupid guy who no one loves now
now you're just making it sad
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this will be my Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer
video there's a whole bunch
of Easter eggs and references so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos Marvel
is releasing a bunch of footage because of ccxp
Brazil Comic-Con this week There's also brand new
footage for Ant-Man the Wasp quantumania a bunch
of new Kang footage so there's a bunch of stuff
to talk about obviously the really big takeaways
here is we get our first look at Adam Warlock In
the Flesh with the gem in his forehead I know
there's lots of questions about the Infinities
don't because he had the Soul Stone in the comics
that's not meant to be the Soul Stone Thanos
atomized this universe's version of the Infinity
Stones even though there was a lot of time travel
Steve Rogers Captain America took the Infinity
Stones back in time to where they stole them from
so in present day they're still atomized chukwudi
abuji is playing the high evolutionary he's the
main villain of the film he's the person who
created rocket he's also the person responsible
for creating that weird looking version of the
United States with all the other humanoid looking
animals kind of like rocket like they're meant
to be creations of his experiments of his kind
of like rocket was does that's why it looks like
the Earth but this is meant to be a foreign planet
we see the bigger version of Groot have his
Hulk out moment we are Groot he says it again
James then also clarified what's going on with
this version of Groot and why he's fundamentally
different from the previous version of Groot
the full-size group that we saw in the first
Guardians of the Galaxy movie but just starting
at the beginning of the trailer footage we'll work
our way through shot by shot talking about Easter
eggs WTF modes obviously they start with the logo
the custom Marvel Studios logo for this is meant
to be like the wood grain of Peter Quill's tape
player in the first movie typically the music
in the Guardians of the Galaxy movies started
in the early to mid 70s and then slowly through
the films kind of worked its way to the late 70s
the song that's playing in this trailer is in the
meantime by spacehog the funny thing about that
song though is that that one is from the 90s so I
don't know if James Gunn is just allowing its use
for the trailer or if it's actually used in the
movie itself because typically the movies are just
70s music we actually saw the new Guardians
of the Galaxy ship debut during the holiday
special recently I did a whole video for that
so I'll link it down in the description below
it's called the Bowie named after David Bowie
because Peter Quill names all their spaceships
after pop stars the other very clear thing is that
they're wearing comic book accurate suits to the
annihilation Conquest run that's the run where
this version of the Guardians of the Galaxy team
came together for the first time even though this
looks like Earth it's meant to be an experiment
that the high evolutionary is running which is
why even though it looks like this American suburb
it's a bunch of humanoid looking aliens this is
flashbacks of Rocket's origin story with a high
evolutionary reaching his hand into Rocket's cage
when he was this little tiny raccoon turning him
into this humanoid creation giving the ability to
talk walk around on two legs James Gunn said that
the third film is mostly about rocket like he's
one of the main characters within the Ensemble
so that's why the high evolutionary is the main
villain the Guardians of the Galaxy movies are all
about bad space dads in the high evolutionaries
like rockets bad space dad as the Guardians are
leaving their ship to jump down to the high
evolutionaries Planet here which looks kind
of like ego The Living Planet like this organic
looking structure notice that the colors of their
spacesuits look like the colors of the Infinity
Stones this is the 2014 version of Gamora there
was a bunch of footage in the d23 version of
the trailer that they didn't include in this
where Peter Quill is meeting her for the first
time again after a big long break in realizing
that she is now the person who is in charge of the
ravagers like she went full Thanos taking over the
ravagers that's why she's wearing the ravager's
uniform here but she's fundamentally a different
person from the previous Gamora because she didn't
go through any of the experiences that that Gamora
went through the pictures he's looking at is a
picture of her and Peter Quill together for the
previous version of Gamora and he's trying to win
her back to the team trying to get her to fall in
love with him again a big part of the movie is
nebula kind of being the one to pull her around
the whole idea in the first two films is that
Gamora tries to be the one to win nebula over to
get her to chill out this time it's nebula doing
that for this version of Gamora they had a little
bit of that during Avengers end game where nebula
was telling her no you don't have to be like this
our father is terrible Thanos isn't going to help
you because Thanos very literally sacrificed her
to get the Soul Stone I think this is meant to be
them back on nowhere but James gonna explain is
that during the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special when things pick up they've purchased
nowhere like they bought the entire head of
this dead Celestial from The Collector which
confirms that he survived Avengers Infinity
War Thanos basically destroyed most of that
place so I think we all thought that he died after
infinity war came out but this just confirms that
he's alive out there the Elders of the universe
are very hard to kill you also notice that Cosmo
the space dog is also with them they confirmed
during the holiday special as well the cosmo of
the space dog gonna be a much bigger character
during this she'll be voiced by Maria bakalova
what I refuse to do any more work while you demean
me all right all right I'm sorry cracklin's still
a big part of the team also the joke here is that
nebula is carrying Peter Quill princess carrying
him like he's been knocked out somehow one of
the big things about nebula during this movie
is it should become much more of a leader within
the team like a more well-adjusted person just in
general even though they have the big joke about
her stealing Bucky's vibranium arm to give it to
Rocket he said the way that she got that is she
literally just ripped it right off of his body
because she knew that rocket wanted it she didn't
sleep with him or we didn't have a relationship
with him or anything like that or trick him
like she literally just showed up ripped it
right off of him and took back off to nowhere I
assume at some point they'll bring it back to him
because he's going to be in the Thunderbolts
movie probably in Captain America four like
he's gonna need that vibranium arm rocket telling
them that he's done running with all this damage
around them is him just wanting to go after the
high evolutionary not running from him anymore
because he's meant to be crazy powerful it's sort
of the same Vibe as Peter Quill going up against
his father ego The Living Planet this is a much
better look at the high evolutionaries home base
it's meant to be the MCU version of half world
where rocket comes from there was an Easter egg
for in the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
notice how it looks a lot like ego The Living
Planet and it is very organic if you couldn't
tell it's basically like the hollowed-out body
of a former giant Celestial being so I wouldn't
be surprised if there's some Celestial connection
to this like it's meant to be a parallel for the
Guardians taking over nowhere which is the head of
a dead Celestial they've been living inside
using the body of this giant dead Celestial
the high evolutionary has been doing the same
thing post all your theories in the comments
though what giant space creature was this this
is just chukwudi aruji as the high evolutionary
performing more experiments on his Creations his
whole thing is he's trying to create the perfect
being the funny thing about Adam Warlock is
that he's meant to be the perfect creation
but he was created by The Sovereign to kill the
Guardians of the Galaxy so it'll be interesting
to see the interaction between him and the high
evolutionary in this film because if you remember
in the comics the high evolutionary is the person
that upgraded Adam Warlock in the comics and gay
gave him the soul gem so even though the soul gem
doesn't exist anymore in present day like it's
atomized I wouldn't be surprised that the high
evolutionary does something similar or has some
Easter egg connection with Adam Warlock during
this film this is the Guardians of the Galaxy
on half World Gamora is with them at this point
then being in the jumpsuits there is also meant
to be a parallel for them in the prison jumpsuits
during the first movie all the scenes of Rocket
during the trailer are starting to make me word
for his character because it sounds like he might
wind up being the one to sacrifice himself during
the movie The Talking otter that rocket is hugging
is Lila his girlfriend in the comics there was
a rumor about Lady Gaga voicing this character
so I wonder if that's actually going to wind up
being true because we don't hear the otter speak
in the trailer but she's meant to be one of the
other creations of the high evolutionary it sounds
like rocket has some kind of relationship with
her at some point Big callback to Guardians of
the Galaxy 2 this is the same type of alien that
they attacked at the beginning of Guardians 2.
this might be connected to when they face Adam
Warlock for the first time in the sovereign's
domain just because this type of alien was
always showing up to try and eat their batteries
we see Will Poulter as Adam Warlock it looks like
they're back on nowhere or somewhere similar he's
meant to be super powerful in the comics he's kind
of like Marvel's version of space Jesus we'll see
how they treat that in the MCU but obviously he's
probably going to be a big character going forward
like this won't be the last time you see Adam
Warlock in a space based movie even though this
is meant to be the last movie with this roster
of the Guardians of the Galaxy which is why I
say that some of them might wind up dying some of
them might retire or go off on their own but they
will continue like the Guardians of the Galaxy
will continue with a new roster Adam Warlock did
join the team during the annihilation Conquest run
where they wore these very same costumes so it is
possible that he winds up joining this version
of the team this is meant to be an homage to
that shot from the first Guardians of the Galaxy
movie where the entire team is walking down the
hallway with Groot saying we are Groot like he
did in the first film but the idea is that this
version of Groot looks different from the original
group because he's meant to be the child of that
group James Gunn confirmed that he's basically
like that groot's child which is why he sounds
just a little bit different itself in diesel but
he sounds just a little different and he looks
a little different and this version of Groot is
meant to be much more socialized having grown up
which is why his personality seems so different
from that original Groot like he's so much more
outgoing than original Groot this is sort of like
groot's Hulk out moment and of course they have
a post-credits scene for the trailer this post
credit scene is just Drax yelling about wanting
to kill people and Peter Quill trying to stop
that like no no we don't want to kill people
there's a bunch of extra footage that was in
the d23 trailer that they didn't put in this
so I'll link my other video for that down in the
description below and at the end of this but they
also released an Ant-Man of the Wasp Quantumania
trailer video I'll do a video for that next so be
sure to subscribe to get that everyone click
here for that video I'll update the link as
soon as I post it and click here for that other
Guardians of the Galaxy trailer video in Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!